catholic-school you credit Catholic
school with making you funny do you
think that's true absolutely Giotto
Catholic school I went to regular public
school but then I would have one day a
week I had to go to Catholic school no
but I went to Catholic school for nine
years and the nuns that when I went to
Catholic school I mean you read today
you read the newspapers or online that
people they the nuns are let's just say
harsh and if a nun hits a kid now they
get sued right parents see that I went
to school if a nun hit me and I went
home went mom mom sister hit me she'd be
like you probably deserved a thwack you
know it's the Italian way to raise
people yeah and so I learned at an early
age if I could make the nun laugh she
wouldn't hit me so yeah yeah because
they could be I mean the old stereotype
is based on what in reality they could
they could be quite strict I was lucky
mine they actually they wore the whole
nun outfit the wimple the wimple but
they were no one was ever hitting us
with a ruler but I have plenty of
friends who got hit with a ruler on the
hand when they did something I figured
that there's really only there's only
three nuns and they do it with mirrors
it's ha ha ha there's the really there's
always that really young nun who always
is the music teacher yeah right we call
her sister Dominica nikinike yeah she
knows absolutely nothing about music but
she can play a zipper this is always
nice and then of course there's that
really really really old nun like every
school has that really really old nun
yes old old nun we had sister Melissa
she was sold she was a topless waitress
the Last Supper okay
that doesn't sound and then of course
the last one would be the the big butch
the big butch nun the big butch Dyke nun
every school has you can always you
always know down because they're the
ones that take a man's name right you
know what I mean like mine was that
you'd be like Sister John Richard you
know sister like that
right I had a nine called sister Richard
marine right I mean like in the halls of
Monte
she was 6 foot tall she weighed about
395 pounds she looked like Dick Butkus
and I've wimple and mustache all the
other kids were afraid of her but I
thought she was kind of cute yeah and
you learn so you said that you could
sometimes you could sometimes make them
happy right you could say oh yeah I
actually this is the old nun that was
telling you about
sister Melissa she was my English
teacher and one day I love this story
I'm sorry I have to tell it one day she
asked me asked the entire class to write
a poem and I couldn't be bothered so I
went home and I was just you know bored
so remember a horse with no name the
song the horse was in the band dude on a
horse with no name yet right well that I
love that song and I thought I'm bored
so I just wrote down the lyrics to a
horse of no name and turned it in as my
poem and the next funny book that's a
very famous song I mean that but she was
a hundred and fifty million year old
Knight
you know good she didn't say he was just
thinking she was still thinking about
that brat da Vinci that she taught me I
turned so I turned it in and the next
day she was handing our papers back and
talking about how some of the people
were better than other people and some
of these papers are good and some of
these papers are good but we have one
person in the class one person who
really poured her soul out you guessed
it Lea delaria come to the front of the
class and read your poem so she didn't
know and she loved it and she loved it
and she made me go and flip a room of 30
kids who obviously all listened to the
radio and I started to read I've been
through the desert on a horse with no
name it's good to be out first the class
starts laughing and this is the best
part she starts screaming at him for
laughing at me what's wrong with you
children
[Laughter]
you're going to hell you're going to
hell hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos
please